My name is Stephanie, I'm from Houston, Texas.
My dad has an unusual job.
He gets to live and work in space,...
...and he's doing lots of experiments up there.
He has to stay there for long periods of time so he's gone a lot.
Yeah, I miss him when he's gone.
I think if we could write a really big message he will be able to see it from space.
He would probably just grab his camera and take a picture...
...'cause he loves to take pictures.
He would be totally caught off guard if he saw a message,...
...and it might make him miss us even more or miss Earth.
I'd probably tell him that I miss him and I love him.
It looks just like my handwriting.
Hi Stephanie!
It's dad.
And I just wanted to call and say I love you and thank you.